[Musique]
la terre était-elle un animal
étrange question qui pourtant va nous
permettre de nous plonger dans notre
passé de créer un pont direct avec notre
histoire mais également de questionner
notre lien avec la régénération
qu'est-ce que l'histoire peut bien nous
apprendre là-dedans
fermez les yeux et imaginez-vous
quelques instants tout Paris résonne
encore de la Révolution et des fracas de
la Révolution française
les brumes guerrières recommencent à
tomber tranquillement sur la cité des
Lumières
durant cette intense moment d'ébullition
au temps politique qu'un intellectuel
une critique un peu particulière va
commencer à émerger
l'homme par ses actes avec sa hache est
capable d'interférer sur le climat
pire encore
il est capable de perturber l'équilibre
mondial du cycle de l'eau
tiens donc
nous arrivons à notre toute première
jonction avec l'histoire
par le passé au XVIIIe siècle nous avons
déjà pensé à la capacité de l'homme
d'interférer voir de dégrader totalement
l'environnement dans lequel il vit
la terre était-elle alors un animal
blessé
la personne royale est toute désignée
comme la principale actrice de cette
destruction méthodique de
l'environnement
le roi a commandé à ses armées une
politique d'expansion
il faut coloniser
il faut réduire son ennemi son voisin
anéant et pour cela le bois est
essentiel les forêts françaises vont
alors être utilisés pour construire la
marine
et aussi pour réussir à tirer la France
et que la France puisse tirer son
épingle du jeu
là dedans
on incuse le roi et on accuse également
les ecclésiastiques d'avoir dégradé la
nature française
rappelons-nous
l'Europe sort alors d'une période qui
est
climatiquement intense
les hivers sont longs les famines
fréquentes et le climat est rude
dans ce moment là on accuse la personne
royale d'être à l'origine de tout cela
c'est la main de l'homme qui pèse sur le
globe
tels sont les mots de François Antoine
rose un ingénieur français né en 172
mais alors
que faire
car selon lui si on ne fait rien la
nature va droit à sa destruction
en effet il prend exemple
avec le Sahara
cette énorme étendue désertique
aurait été provoqué à cause d'une
surexploitation forestière qui durant
des siècles et des siècles auraient
exploité ces terres jusqu'à rendre cette
énorme vase et c'est énorme zone aride
mais alors comment échapper à ça
rush imagine un plan en trois phases
la première phase est une phase de
compréhension il faut étudier calculer
mesurer en soi comprendre le problème et
comprendre pourquoi l'humain là dedans
est un acteur principal
la deuxième phase
est la phase de régénération c'est une
phase d'action il va falloir replanter
reboiser
mener de vastes politiques de
pisciculture afin de ramener les
poissons dans les eaux qui en sont
désertés
enfin troisième phase l'objectif final
qui est une nature régénère les flancs
des montagnes ont à nouveau des forêts
la pluie recommence à tomber
l'équilibre est le cycle de l'eau est à
nouveau
et équilibré
et enfin
l'humain l'homme peut de nouveau vivre
dans un habitat régénéré
la science et ses apôtres vont alors se
saisir de cette mission d'ordre quasi
divin
il faut pour cela que cette élite
intellectuelle se saisisse de ses
multiples problèmes
réussissent à les comprendre mais a
également besoin d'une main d'oeuvre car
on ne Téra forme pas tout le territoire
français en étant qu'une poignée
d'intellectuel qui se charpille sur les
méthodes entreprendre
l'industrialisation a mis sur le banc
énormément d'ouvriers qui sont alors
menacés par les affres du chômage
les indigents comme on les appelait à
cette époque vont alors être utilisés
comme les chevilles ouvrières de cette
régénération
il faut qu'ils arrivent à développer il
faut qu'ils arrivent à construire cette
nature dégradée par le roi
mais
ils sont également pointés du doigt
depuis que les forêts royales ont été
rendues publiques
ils ne sont que égoïstes
ils ne sont que avidités
ils ont recommencé à utiliser le bois
sans même réfléchir à l'aspect
communautaire on lit alors des discours
politiques qui rejettent toute la faute
sur eux
c'était avant à cause du roi maintenant
c'est à cause de vous
cela ne fait-il pas écho
chez certains d'entre vous à certains
discours politiques que nous avons pu
entendre si elle a ou certains sont
accusés par d'autres
de trop consommer
de trop regarder de vidéos sur YouTube
de trop voyager en avion
ce type de discours culpabilisateur
existent depuis très longtemps
et risque probablement de continuer
longtemps
à nous empoisonner
mais ce n'est pas la seule inspiration
que nous arrivons à trouver
on y trouve aussi cette étrange qu'au
niveau avec ses humains du passé qui
traversait des angoisses similaires aux
nôtres qui se posaient déjà des
questions qu'on se pose nous-mêmes
et enfin si on veut reprendre cette
étape en trois plans
je dirais que on se situe entre la phase
une et la phase 2 nous avons compris le
problème nous l'avons mesuré en nous
alerte depuis longtemps du mur que nous
allons nous prendre mais il nous manque
le petit truc
la petite bille qui nous permettra de
passer de la phase de compréhension à la
phase d'action
la terre était-elle alors un animal
politique
la régénération en histoire n'est pas
qu'une affaire révolutionnaire c'est
aussi une périodes historique
extrêmement précise dans notre histoire
en Suisse elle s'étend de 1830 à 1847 à
comme principal acteur les forces
mais avant ça un petit peu de contexte
en 1814 le spectre napoléonien et enfin
battu les anciennes élites
conservatrices reprennent le pouvoir
et les aristocraties veulent remettre
les héritiers sur le trône
durant ce moment-là les libéraux vont se
constituer comme une force d'opposition
il faut instaurer les libertés qui pour
nous nous paraissent totalement acquises
liberté de la presse liberté
d'expression liberté de se réunir
liberté de prière liberté d'industrie
liberté d'entreprendre
pour faire cela les libéraux vont mener
une révolution tout à fait illégale d'un
coup de plume ils vont tracer les
anciennes constitutions
du passé faisons table rase
on régénère notre propre rapport à
l'ordre législatif on réécrit nos lois
tout ça dans un pacifisme relatif
quasiment aucune effusion de sang et
pourtant on repense totalement notre
manière de penser on repense totalement
notre rapport au monde
n'est-ce pas là incroyable
nous avons déjà fait ces changements par
le passé nous avons déjà eu le courage
de mener ces révolutions pacifistes et
je pense que là-dedans nous pouvons en
tirer une inspiration nous pouvons en
tirer un élan qui peut également nous
motiver à changer à changer en
nous-mêmes et également changer la
société
pourtant on atteint la limite
car
à trop vouloir chercher des similitudes
on pourrait peut-être tomber dans le
même piège que même ce sont tendu
car cette époque-là le 19e siècle
c'était également le colonialisme
c'est le racisme institutionnalisé c'est
la construction des premières grandes
industries qui vont mener à de massives
pollution
c'est le départ du capitalisme prédateur
dans lequel nous sommes encore
totalement empêtrés qui détruit vis et
nature pour assurer son accroissement
c'est également le début de mécanisme
économique dont nous sommes encore
prisonniers
mais alors pourquoi vous raconter tout
ça
quel est le sens de toute façon c'est
foutu
et bien
déjà parce que ça permet de répondre à
cet angoisse qui moi mettre un de plus
en plus
ce sentiment de peur
de faiblesse face
à un combat face à un ennemi qui me
paraît invincible me plonger dans le
passé et côtoyer ses intelligences
d'hier me permettent de me dire que je
ne suis pas tout seul
par le passé des gens ce sont déjà posé
des questions similaires au miennes des
gens ont également traversé des
angoisses qui ressemblaient à ce que
j'avais et pourtant ils ont trouvé la
force de continuer ils ont trouvé la
force de persévérer malgré un avenir
incertain et la peur du lendemain
ne sommes-nous pas comme eux
mais là dedans c'est aussi trouver ces
petits gestes trouver
ces moments dans l'histoire où on voit
que des actes autant individuels que
collectifs
peuvent mener à de grandes choses des
petits gestes du quotidien aux grandes
révolution et je pense aussi que dans
cette histoire c'est le moment où on
peut trouver
cette petite bille qui peut nous
permettre de passer de la phase de
compréhension à la phase d'action
la terre était-elle alors un animal
divin vous savez durant cette période
révolutionnaire on voyait la terre comme
un grand organisme
ces fleuves ces rivières ces montagnes
étaient autant de parties différentes de
ce corps céleste qui voguait comme ça
dans le vide intersidéral
l'eau y était vu comme une analogie au
sang qui coule dans nos propres veines
et les révolutionnaires pour se
débarrasser de siècles de domination
chrétienne vont réenchanter
spiritualisé le lien qu'ils
entretiennent avec Mère Nature
régénérer ce lien
recréer un horizon des possibles voilà à
quoi ils vont s'atteler
loin de moi l'idée de vouloir vous
emmener dans une sombre secte
régénératrice serait un peu mal venu et
sûrement pas très efficace mais je pense
que ici réside peut-être le moyen de
répondre à nos problèmes axiologiques
dont nous sommes fortement prisonniers
c'est également le moment
où on peut s'extraire de notre condition
matérielle et réussir à sortir des
sentiers battus
que faire alors
pour régénérer ce lien
réussir à approfondir cette relation
avec le divin
la terre était-elle un animal
derrière cet étrange question se cache
un lien direct avec notre histoire un
pont unique avec notre passé certains de
nos ancêtres se posaient des questions
similaires au nôtres
se poser des problématiques qui
ressemblent à celles que nous nous
posons actuellement et pourtant ils ont
trouvé la force de conviction de
continuer à avancer malgré l'adversité
devons-nous
réellement laisser la terre ne restez
qu'un animal économique je ne pense pas
il faut réussir à s'élever
en cela l'histoire peut nous apprendre
beaucoup
par le passé
nous avons trouvé la force de tenter
d'initier ce mouvement cette petite
bille dont je vous parlais pour passer
de la phase 1 à la phase 2
je pense nous pouvons tous constater
ensemble que c'est un relatif échec mais
cela doit-il nous empêcher d'essayer
par le passé des révolutionnaires
libéraux ont réussi d'un coup de plume à
redessiner totalement l'ordre légal
ils y sont arrivés
par le passé des humains ont tenté de
régénérer ce lien profond qui les
unissait à la nature et ont réussi grâce
à la spiritualité à réenchanter leur
horizon des possibles
ils y sont arrivés
alors
pourquoi pas nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]